the shadow hunters
uh
how many episodes did you do that a year
we did our first season was 13 and then
we did um
20 and 20 and then we did a two episode
series finale so all in all 55 episodes
you see how though you can remember i
know you can when you did 13 episodes
how much nicer that was and easier and
you had a bigger break and it wasn't as
but when you do 20 episodes you're there
for eight nine months
and it's pretty taxing it's not you know
it's not easy people say being an actor
is so easy and we're just but it's not
it's not like it's not a glamorous job
really
no i mean look i've i've had you're
gonna say about the dust and the wind i
might get
you know you
say that it might become a challenge but
remember i've been covered in
blood and dust you have you know slime
and
all sorts of stuff for the last seven
eight years i'm used to it i love it i
love being in the trenches i love being
my favorite days on set are being head
to toe covered in blood mud sweat and
tears you're a rarity in the trenches
yeah so bring on the dust and the wind
all we are is dust and the so you
remember that song do you remember that
i would hope so i mean what are you
you're 26 now
far more mature than i'll ever be at 26.
no yep you are
uh the new shadowhunters podcast
i'm joining your world now
what do you mean
the podcast world oh the podcast world
yes yes yeah who approached you about
this
so i started talking to uh one of our
producers um at this company called
propagate about creating content and
what
else we could do working together just
during the pandemic what else can i do
being a creative someone who wants to be
a multi-hyphenate how can i get involved
and
one of our producers turned to me and
went
you did the show shadowhunters and you
seem to have a really
big fan base for it like there's a
there's a really big fandom that's still
very active i mean oh you have no idea
um and she said well
what if you were to do a podcast maybe
you know re-watching episodes or
interviewing people and
and we started talking and developing it
and and i reached out to dom and said
dom sherwood who played jace my love
interest on the show
i reached out to him and said hey would
you want to
go on this walk down memory lane would
you want to
go back and rewatch and and bring on
some of the rest of the shadow fam and
interview people and discuss this and
and he was totally on board because this
fandom
is
so incredible and i know we've talked
about it at length before but you know
they've they've done so many incredible
things over the years and taken the show
beyond or taking the fandom beyond us
and be on the show and beyond our
characters and the story and created
this beautiful community
and
you know for me shadowhunters was age 19
to 23. it was such a formative part of
my life and be able to look back on it
now and
relive that and see where all of the
people that were so instrumental in that
process are now and the amazing things
they've done and be able to kind of
continue to celebrate that family it's
really really a wonderful experience
return to the shadows
with dominic sherwood
and catherine mcnamara
indeed wow when is this is it already
going
it is yeah we've started releasing
episodes i think we have about
i want to say
seven or eight episodes out already
really
yeah
and so what do you do do you go back and
watch the episode and then talk about it
so we alternate so dom and i will go
through and the two of us will do a
re-watch of an episode where we
basically break down when the episode
was shot who directed it who wrote it
what the synopsis is and then kind of
talk about it and share as many little
tidbits and stories and all the stuff
we've never been able to talk about
before basically would you go back to uh
would you go back to the shadows would
you go back to shadowhunters if they did
like a tv movie or they wanted to do
another season uh
in a heartbeat really in an absolute
heartbeat yeah you loved it that much
there's not much is there anything that
you don't love or didn't like filming or
didn't like working on without t you
don't have to tell me but has there ever
been something that you're like oh i
wouldn't do that again
um
maybe i mean there's things that have
been more difficult than others but
not because of the story or because of
the character or or you know mostly
because of the people i worked with it's
it's all i've been very lucky in that
the majority of the experiences that
i've had in this industry have been
wonderful and learning experiences and
and things that i would go back to and
people that i would go back to
i mean maybe i'm just a stubborn
optimist
but
yeah
i love what i do yeah